[Musique]
bonjour
marlène maintenant je ne comprends rien
à cette génération
comment se fait-il qu'il n'y ait
personne à nos ateliers jazz
bonjour philippe bonjour philippe
personnellement je trouve que vous
atelier de musique sont une très bonne
idée
demain très peu de lycée propose des
initiatives aussi épanouie stendhal aux
élèves alors que le problème mais le
problème c'est que le diable n'a pas de
succès chez nos élèves
vous avez pas encore me parler d'europe
la finale je ne commente pas sûr que
vous donnerez ce que l'on parle de ce
style de musique que c'est pas un style
de musique danse et les blettes objectif
vous êtes féru de diass ok vous aviez
même groupe
un carton alors c'était pas un groupe
c'est un carton en quartet bon écouter
même si je fais l'effort de mettre de
côté le fait que je trouve que le rap
c'est de la merde ça reste une activité
qui ne demandent aucun travail et vous
savez vous mieux que tout le monde ici
que c'est exactement l'inversé de ce que
je compte leur inculquer et mais c'est
vraiment dommage et figurez vous que je
connais en rappeur très talentueux qui
était partant pour des abonnés d'entre
eux d'ici qui sont médine
vous direz à ce médine que nous ne
sommes pas intéressés voilà on ne fait
vraiment pas discuter avec vous et ce
qui m'étonne c'est de découvrir un jeune
comme vous avec des idées de sujets
moerlen alors bon jouer au moins essayer
que les élèves n'aient pas conscience
des choses je peux difficilement leur en
vouloir
mais quand c'est mes propres collègues
qui sont aveuglés ne sait pas quoi faire
après on est peut-être juste refermer
maintenant tu vas pas tes maîtres toi
aussi et c'est bon je suis avec toi je
me pose juste la question ferait un bon
petit gims de temps en temps ça fait pas
de mal tu plaisantes ya rien de plus
pauvres en paroles que ça me demanda la
ligne j'ai beaucoup non n'importe qui
peut écrire ça pourtant tu m'as jamais
dit un truc pareil
pardon bah ouais si c'est si facile
vas-y on rencontre un truc du style tu
m'as toujours ébloui un peu comme une
loupe comme une lente parce qu'une
langue ça et vous y danser justement
faible en termes de luminosité philippe
s'est tu d'accord répond d'un nombre on
va y venir
elle a fait on ne ment n'aime pas là
pour toi elle fait courir après ce
et se targue odeur laissée faire tu me
cherches pour tous mes frères mes soeurs
m'a coûté ma mère tout à donner ces
trois mères mais comment je vais faire
elle m'a fait rencontrer les guetteurs
mamie des cas qu'il balayait tellement
papeete jamais existé
met en retard tout dormi là je m'excuse
arrive
non mais de mettre énervé il ya au sujet
du rap c'était pure il au sujet toi le
rap c'est quoi ça alors hop le rap le
style de musique le rap jamais entendu
ça de ma vie
excuse moi ah non on en parlait hier
soir le rap quoi le rappellera pirates
différentes de celles qui ont tous du
matin au soir le rap voilà
[Musique]
oui bah ça c'est du rail tu me parles du
rail bon on parle un break ce soir allez
je vais bosser bisous
[Musique]
sky
à
[Musique]
bonjour philippe faut absolument qu'on
parle du conseil de discipline de judy
dans l'aisne notre urgence
ah oui on a parlé de quoi leur jeu votre
passion le thiès mais encore je vous ai
proposé une de mes connaissances comme
intervenant connaissance qui s'appelle
me jean
le rappeur de croix le rappeur qui fait
du rap le rappeur sera pas de quoi vous
voulez parler possible bon il faut
absolument que je rencontre aujourd'hui
j'ai pu vous aurez existe un problème
merci non mais certains ferries oui ça
va aller sauvage et non mais je vous
envoie ses coordonnées je vois bien il
est souvent au rendez vous et vous vous
dites ajouté
[Musique]
vous êtes si en fait oui vous vous
attendiez à quoi mène un palace a
précisé sam aurait rassuré si vous aviez
été un rappeur quoi un rappeur laissé
tomber ne vous mettez pas de barrière
philippe je ne suis pas dans le jugement
a laissé le temps pour j'en suis fière
j'étais dans un monde totalement
différent
un monde dans lequel le style de musique
dont je vous parle là le rap était
partout le style le plus populaire du
monde et aujourd'hui je me réveille dans
un monde où le rap n'existe pas où
personne n'en a jamais entendu parler et
comment vous expliquez ça selon je sais
pas enfin j'ai souhaité que le rap n'est
jamais exister parce que je déteste ce
suite de musique mais vous devriez être
content ben oui mais non parce que c'est
pas mon monde c'est ce qui vous arrive
c'est rien du tout avant ce que vous
appelez le rap c'est ça vous l'avez
associés potentiellement un traumatisme
et du coup quand on aura trouvé ensemble
ce traumatisme
eh bien vous pourrez retrouver votre
monde d'avant tout à fait normalement à
quoi ressemble ce style de musique comme
il n'existe pas c'est un peu compliqué à
décrire a justement ce qui m'intéresse
c'est comment vous allez le décrire
philippe vous devez passer par cette
étape et ben en fait ça repose
principalement sur la vitesse
ça va beaucoup plus vite que les paroles
d'une chanson classique mais en gardant
les rimes très bien notre émoi bon alors
juste comme je connais pas de paroles
par coeur de chansons je vais devoir
improviser et ça risque de pas être
incroyable d'accord allô allô ton
téléphone sonne ça résonne dans la cage
d'escalier leçon nixon et résonnent dans
la nuit car tu as fait le mauvais choix
dans ta vie tu as tout perdu
tu n'as rien reçu rue de la rue nu tapo
mu la musique est bonne est ce que la
musique est bonne oui la musique est
bonne
sohn résonne comme ton téléphone dans
l'année laissons ça rime pas des masses
est assez négatif mais cette phase est
compris le piège et les rimes c'est
compliqué en fait je pense qu'on aura un
peu plus de travail que prévu pour
guérir de sans toit
[Musique]
philippe il faut absolument qu'on parle
du prochain conseil de discipline je
vous écoute
comme vous avez la majorité des
enseignants sont pour l'exclusion
définitive
depuis que je travaille ici je n'ai
jamais exclu en rêve définitivement et
je compte bien continuer comme ça bon je
sais bien mais c'est la troisième
commission disciplinaire de cet élève il
vous faut d'abord le troisième oeil qui
on parle jamais de lundi nguema le
landry nguema mais ça nous élève le plus
prometteur
non mais vous rigolez il n'a pas fait un
contrôle depuis des mois et il aurait
agressé deux de ses proches dans ce cas
un angle différent
pardon rien je pensais à autre chose
philippe je compte vraiment sur vous sur
ce coup là la commission a lu jeudi
il faut que vous soyez prêt à l'exclure
définitivement une vo lun
il en permanence qui sèche le court pour
aller en permanence ouais il écrit il
trie quoi tu bats il écrit mais ne rompt
jamais de copies bombe afin de revenir
ok
[Musique]
bonjour lambris jours
alors qu'est ce qui se passe comment ça
se passe quoi tu sais que tu es sur le
point de se faire renvoyer
et alors qu'est ce que je m'en fous
comment c'est possible que tu puisses en
[ __ ] l'école c'est pas pour moi etc
d'autres problèmes façon vous serez bien
content que je serai plus là qui sera
content vous tout cela
tous ceux qui veulent comprendre que je
suis pas ma place ici évidemment que t
as ta place ici est-ce que tu réalises
le potentiel que tu as acheté ma gueule
mais non pas du tout landry tu es très
prometteur et vas-y ça fait deux ans
nous dit le contraire
vous devez être un câble avant la
commission mais non ben alors arrêtez de
mentir ça va je reviens il ya un truc
qui te tracasse
c'est un de mes élèves qui étaient
extrêmement doué un jour et qui
soudainement de manière complètement son
naturel est devenu le pire élève de mon
établissement en bout décidément c'est
la journée des trucs bizarres pour toi
comment ça à temps ce matin tu me parles
un style de musique qui est complètement
inconnu rap rap est maintenant là tu me
parles un élève qui soudainement devient
mauvais c'est fou quand même mais se dit
quoi landry mon élève faisait du rap
sans drap son comportement ses dérivés
alors ces foules bien que l'érable peut
faire procès jeune et belle problème est
réglé tout à fait
salut les jeunes
ça va
genre on peut se parler bouger le
monsieur pardon
c'est pas vous respectez ici en plus de
moi je serai plus votre élève mais
justement à propos de ça je pense qu'on
peut éviter ton exclusion vas-y vas-y je
veux pas parler de ça je sais que tu
écris en terme
je pense que ce que tu écris même si je
suis pas encore sûr c'est peut-être du
rap à l'eau ouais vas y arrive on
choisit les gars je bouge
landry à temps landry
qu'est-ce que
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous écoutez comme musique
vous
mylène farmer
t'entends pas ou quoi j'étais dit mylène
farmer wen jia quan maroc je te fout de
sa gueule elle mylène farmer tu la
respectes c'est la seule qui parle de
nous dans ces sons elle a invité dans
aucune émission comme nos frères
elle parle de vous sa mère tk
à côté je parle de quoi tout est ko à
côté c'est les bâtiments tout est
délabré c'est le quartier ouest où les
idéaux
les murs abîmés a scellé rêve
inatteignable
je cherche une à
am qui pourra m'aider dû en trouver des
meufs et puis voici c'est dur de faire
confiance à l'autre cnra
si on est enchanté des anges en dés si
nous la génération désenchantée les mecs
de quartier on tient ça et puis il
manque plus de respect à moulins de
forme et je te dirai d'accord oui bon et
ben bonne journée
merci hein
tous ces profs sont catégoriques donc je
pense qu'il ya plus rien dire nous avons
entendu ce côté enseignants avaient à
dire linguiste à quoi tu t'exprimes
n'ont rien à dire non mais t'es sûr tu
as vraiment rien à dire ouais bon ben
maintenant nous allons procéder à la
délibération temps des mois je je pense
que landry a des choses à dire justement
quoi je pense que ce qu'il a écrit sans
cesse la en salle de permanence
c'est tout ce qu'il ressent et qu'il
n'arrive pas à exprimer je me trompe je
sais pas mais qu'est-ce que ça va
changer de façon eh ben je t'offre le
moyen de t'exprimer lité note que ma
confiance je vous avoir sûr que je passe
là fini écoutez le je sais même pas si
le monde ou si c'est le manque fnj
prépare ton futur mais home ou futurs ya
des [ __ ] guillemets tout part en
couille le cousin a pris perpet la
daronne oncle planète ya des boutres sur
le net pas que le band faut être
fouettée et vous ne prenez la tête parce
que je porte une casquette mais
qu'est-ce qui va pas chez vous je suis
bloqué je peux pas j'ai bout avoir de
l'espoir j'ai beau un cocktail de sun
j'ai bu à lennik sa mère tout va trop
vite alors que je suis quand premier
asmodée conseille d'écouter la
conseillère de 6,7 posséder il ya les
cours sont offerts façon c'est comme
d'hab vous allez retenir que mes
insultes et mes excès pour être vexé car
je vous donne accès à toutes mes
névroses nat croire que c'est toujours
pas à ses jupes à rousseau j'écris pas
comme plus cauchy grippe a comme ceux-là
j'écris pas comme voltaire qui me
passent vos commentaires et vos cheveux
pas les faire j'ai la haine contre ses
propres qui me comprenne qui gâche mon
potentiel veulent voir en bas de
l'échelle moi j'en garde des séquelles
c'est un appel à l'aide
ouais un appel à l'aide merci lundi
avoir délibéré maintenant
[Musique]